I am about to read your hands
and tell you what it means
the first step
is to put your hands together
and look at the hand line you have
now
that you have analyzed your hand lines
I'll tell you what it means
number 1 if your left hand line
is lower than the one on the right
it means that you are independent
generally
you keep your opinion to yourself
and you become wiser and wiser
over the years
and finally
you are a very romantic person
number 2 if your left hand line
is higher than the one on the right
"it means that
you are a person who likes challenges
you-are a confident person
and you don't rush
in a relationship
number 3
if your hand lines are the same
it means that you-are strong-minded
and surely charming
you-are soft and sensitive
and you care about the opinion of others
you want a stable relationship
you are thirsty for love
but you don't say it